i want to make a quick clarification to
the last video and then think about
think about what for what's friction up
to when the block is actually moving so
in the last video we started off with
the block being stationary we knew that
the parallel component of the force of
gravity on that block was 49 newtons
downwards down the slope and when so the
block was stationary we said there must
be an offsetting force and we said
that's the force of friction and it must
be 49 newtons upwards and so they
completely net out in that direction
now what we said is we're going to keep
applying a little bit more a little bit
more force until we can budge until we
can budge this block to start
accelerating downwards and i said i
applied i kept i kept applying a little
bit more force a little bit more force
until i get to one newton and then the
block started to budge so at that point
when it started to budge i'm applying
this one newton over here right over
here there's already 49 newtons of force
or the component of gravity
in this direction so
combined we're providing 50 units to
just start budging it to just overcome
the force of friction the one thing i
want to clarify here is this this whole
time the force of friction was not
constant at 49 newtons when it was when
it was when i wasn't messing with this
block and the parallel component of the
force was 49 newtons then the force of
friction was 49 newtons when i started
to press on it a little bit apply a
little bit of force maybe i fried a
tenth of a newton on top of that then
the force of friction was 49th and 1
10th newton because it was still
providing enough force so that this
block was not moving then maybe i
applied half a newton
and so the total force in the downward
direction would have been 49 and a half
newtons but if it still was not moving
then the force of friction was still
completely overcoming it so the force of
friction at that point must have been 49
and a half newtons all the way up to the
combined force in the downward direction
being 49.999
newtons and then the force of friction
was still
49.99999 newtons all the way until i hit
50 newtons and then the block started to
budge which tells us that the force of
friction now all of a sudden or at least
a force of static friction all of a
sudden now couldn't keep up and it
started to accelerate downwards so i
want to so in that static scenario the
force of friction changed as i applied
as i applied more or less force in this
downward direction now with that out of
the way let's take a different scenario
let's let me just redraw that same block
just since all of this since all of this
is getting messy
so we have the same block
we have the same block and as we said in
the last video we're now assuming that
this is wood on wood
so this is the wedge
this is the block right over here
we know that the component of gravity
that is parallel to the
plane right there is 49 newtons
we know that this is 49 newtons we know
the component of gravity that is
perpendicular to the plane we figured
out this two videos ago
is 49 square roots of 3 newtons 49
square roots of 3 newtons we know that
this block is not accelerating in this
normal direction so there must be some
force counteracting gravity in that
direction and that's the normal force of
the wedge on the block
so that is going in that direction at 49
square roots of 3 newtons and now
instead of assuming that this block is
stationary let's assume that it's moving
with a constant velocity
so now we're dealing with we do that in
a different color so now we're dealing
with a
scenario where the block has a constant
velocity
constant
and for the sake of this for the sake of
this video we'll assume that that
constant velocity is we'll assume that
constant velocity is downward and so the
constant velocity
v
is equal to i don't know let's say it is
five meters per second down
down
the wedge or down the ramp or i guess we
could say in the direction that is
parallel to the surface of the ramp so
it's in this direction right over here
so that's the constant velocity
so what are all the forces at play and
be very careful here there might be a
temptation says okay you know there's a
net force here we're moving so maybe
that's the net force is causing the move
but remember remember this is super
important if you have this is newton's
first law if you have a net force if you
have an unbalanced force it will cause
it to accelerate
and we are not accelerating here we have
a constant velocity
we are not accelerating
not accelerating here
so if you're not accelerating in the in
that direction that that means that the
force in that direction must be balanced
so there must be some force acting
acting in the exactly opposite direction
that keeps this thing from accelerating
downwards and so it must be exactly 49
newtons in the opposite direction and as
you can imagine this is the force of
friction this right over here is the
force of friction and the difference
between this video and the last video is
last time friction was static even at 49
newtons the box was stationary you had
to keep nudging until you get to 50 news
then it started moving here we're just
jumping into this picture where we just
see a box that's moving down the slope
at five meters per second so we don't
know how much force it took to overcome
static friction but we do know that
there is some force of friction that is
keeping this box from accelerating
that's keeping it at a constant velocity
that is completely negating the parallel
component of the force of gravity
parallel to parallel to the surface of
this plane so given this let's calculate
another coefficient of friction but this
is going to be the coefficient of
kinetic friction because now we are
moving down the block and i'll do a
video on why
sometimes the coefficient of static
friction can be different than the
coefficient of kinetic friction so the
coefficient of kinetic friction
we'll write it so this is the greek
letter mu
greek letter mu and we put this little
lowerca we put this k here for kinetic
or you can kind of say moving friction
is going to be equal to the force of
friction
so it's going to be or i should say the
magnitude of the force of friction
the magnitude of the force of friction
over
over the normal force over the normal
force
over or as to say the magnitude the
magnitude of the normal force and you
can derive this experimentally one if
you just observed this whole thing going
on you knew the mass of the block so you
knew this the component of gravity
that's going in this direction if you
knew this angle was 30 degrees from the
last situation you could figure out this
coefficient of kinetic friction and
what's cool about this is this is in
general going to be true for any two
materials that are like this so you know
maybe this is a certain type of wood on
a certain type of wood or a certain type
of sandpaper on a certain type of
sandpaper whatever you're talking about
and then you can use that to make
predictions if the incline was different
or if the mass was different or even if
you were on a different planet or if
someone was pressing down on this block
that would change the normal force
so given this right here let's figure
out for the sake of doing it the
coefficient of kinetic friction here
coefficient of kinetic friction the
force of friction here completely
offsetting the parallel force of gravity
parallel to the surface is 49 newtons
and the normal force here the force of
contact between these two these two
things this block and this wedge is 49
square roots of 3 newtons
49 squares to 3 newtons
newtons so we get 1 over the square root
of 3 and let me get the calculator out
to get an actual number here so we have
1 divided by the square root of 3
which gives us 0.5 i'll just round .58
is equal to
0.58 and there's no units here because
the units cancel out it's a unitless
measurement now the interesting thing
here is that the coefficient the way
i've set up this problem the coefficient
of kinetic friction is lower if we
assume the same materials than the
coefficient of static friction was and
for some materials they're usually they
might not be that different but for
other materials the kinetic friction can
be lower than static friction you never
see a situation where static friction is
lower the coefficient of static friction
at least that i know of is lower than
kinetic friction but you do see
situations where the coefficient of
kinetic friction is lower is lower than
the coefficient of static friction that
once
once something is moving
once something is moving for some reason
and we'll theorize why that might be for
some reason friction is a little less
potent than when something is stationary
so we can say this generally that the
coefficient of kinetic friction is less
than or equal to the coefficient the
coefficient of static friction it's a
little bit easier or friction provides a
little less or or less than or equal to
the force once something's moving than
when something is stationary so i'll
think about that a little bit deeper in
the next video